so miles michaelis is on the mound for
saint louis and last time out he seemed
to be a lot sharper than the previous
starts that he's had he was really sharp
especially with his off speed head the
feel for the slider and the curve ball
able to throw those things in getting
deeper into games and getting a lot of
ground ball out three two lifted in the
air out to left newt barr is over and
makes the catch on the run
near the line in left field one of one
down for william thomas and adamus
shoots out with the right field to base
head willie will stop it first don't
need to push that quad injury
when you don't have to it'll be a one
out single first hit of the game for
milwaukee so back-to-back hits and
eduardo escobar is the hitter he is
tonight's clean-up hitter
that is just a straight whiff by kisser
throw to third is late
i don't know if he was crossed up or not
it goes all the way back to the brick
wall behind home plate both runners will
advance on a wild pitch so runners at
second and third two bowls one strike on
escobar and he pulls that one on the
ground adamus will come in to score
goldsmith goes to the bag so the brewers
strike first tonight
and the wild pitch costs michaelis a run
and daniel vogelbeck coming up and it's
a strikeout
his first strikeout of the night as the
brewers pick up a run and it's one
nothing adrian hauser yeah he's making
his third start in september against the
cardinals remember back on september 4th
complete game shutout victory against st
louis back at home his new bar sends it
out to shallow right sinking for a base
hit drops in front of jackie bradley jr
a blue face hit and now we'll walk and
dylan carlson will hit on the ground
over his peterson shovels it to adamus
though
not in time they are loaded up vader
runs extremely well he's a tough guy to
double up swain ground ball hit to short
adamus there's one to first double play
had to go right to willie adamus in a
perfect feed 643 and hauser the ultimate
equalizer with that sinker top of the
order jace peterson leads off for the
crew peterson swings and he goes down on
strikes 88 miles an hour on the cutter
down and in that strikeout is the third
for miles michaelis and the brewers you
have a base runner now for eduardo
escobar inside corner strike three
called escobar threw up the arms and on
a delayed call nick's nick lynch rings
up escobar
adrian hauser working a one two three
bottom of the second inning back out
there here in the bottom of the third
that's a hot shot right at adamus who
has been busy tonight he makes a play
and one away here in the third inning a
couple of quick and efficient outs for
adrian hauser here two pitch here's a
grounder to short adamus
picks it up fires over to first and it's
a one two three for hauser here daniel
will go back leads off the top of the
fourth for the brewers
vogel back that is a fair ball just
inside the bag hits the sidewall and
vogelback playing a little pepper with
miles michaelis that's a leadoff single
chops down on it to get on top of it
make sure you don't pop it up right at
joe west look out joe yeah joe so what a
way now for jackie bradley jr and a
ground ball golden knocks it down vogle
back in a rundown and paul goldschmidt
is as smart
of a baseball player that you will find
dylan carlson we're in the bottom of the
fourth inning with milwaukee leading one
to nothing and the 3-2 pitch is a ground
ball fair past vogel back
off the sidewall carlson
to second base and a leadoff double for
st louis he's just able to get to the
barrel to it shoot it right down this
first base line got something going
again here is matt carpenter walked his
first time up
and carpenter hits a high fly ball
right center at the wall and caught
carlson tagging up from second to third
as matt carpenter gave it a ride an
opportunity here with runner on third
less than two outs
and that's a little tapper it's gonna
hold the runner at third hauser's throw
is in time better be quick that worked
out beautifully for hauser makes a nice
play now it'll be up to paul the young
and the brewers can return that infield
back to normal depth ground ball to
short backhanded by adamus fires to
first it's low but dug out by vogelback
and the inning is over so hauser works
around that lead off double and puts up
yet another zero here manny pina adrian
hauser and then jace peterson against
miles michaelis there's a ball in the
dirt but pina can't hold up and it's a
strikeout and that's number five for
miles michaelis
there's back-to-back strikeout six
tonight for michaelis cardinals are over
five with runners in scoring position
tonight and now it's newt barr who is
one for two 0-2 pitch swinging a miss he
struck him out with a high fastball
first strike out of the game for adrian
hauser five scoreless miles michael is
now pitching into the sixth inning and
doing so looking fairly sharp he has
struck out six four hits allowed he's
walked one
and the check swing and strikeout number
seven and adamus is one for three
tonight and has scored the only run for
milwaukee and it brings in yelich swing
a line drive base hit to left
yelich two for two he's on base for a
third time in the game two outs and
daniel vogelbach oh vogelback gets into
one high fly ball right field and this
one is gonna fly out of here
daniel vogelback
two-run home run with two outs in the
sixth inning the brewers lead it three
to nothing now as vogelback pops his
ninth of the season this is such a quick
stroke a quick bat by daniel vogelback
and the ball just jumped off his back
matty pina will start it for milwaukee
miller slings one in manny pina gets
into one
that one's not coming back it is way up
there in big mac land manny pena with
number 13 on the year it is four nothing
brewers a mistake by andrew miller and
manny pina back legging one that time
and now it's jack flaherty coming out of
the bullpen for st louis they'd love for
him to be an impact guy potentially in
october
basketball catches the outside corner
and a strikeout for flaherty daniel
vogel back two for three today
shallow right center
oh what a catch
rondo the second baseman all the way out
in shallow center
what a play see where rondon starts he's
already playing way out there and right
field ranges a long way that is not an
easy play but he makes it look easy
runners at first and second manny pina
is line to center struck out and hit a
long home run into big mac land to one
pitch is hit high in the air to right
field backing up is carlson back
pedaling and he makes the play and just
on the warning track so pena gave
another one a ride but clarity puts up a
zero two odd walk and now dylan carlson
the cardinals with just three hits
tonight they've been out hit nine three
and they trail four nothing three two
pitch when it goes strike three called
on a breaking ball on the inside corner
carlson couldn't believe it it was a
perfect pitch for aaron ashby four to
nothing and the 17-game winning streak
may be in jeopardy tonight that is a
called strike three 98 mile an hour
fastball from athlete three strikeouts
for aaron ashby man goodness gracious
aaron ashby is just
firing bullets in there and bader is
strikeout victim number four cardinals
down to their last out 2-2 pitch and a
swing at a miss ashby strikes out the
side and the 17-game winning streak
comes to a close
the fans applauding the cardinals
despite the fact that they lose a streak
that comes to an end a streak that we've
never seen in st louis and we may never
see it again